i believe in driving defensively
but with an offensive mindset like the
way the ravens play defense when that
ball's in the air
it's mine
that's my ball i'm comedian ryan sickler
and this is my stepson derek crawford
while we were on quarantine class might
have been out but school was still in
session all right let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one
in your literal hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
look at it
look at aloha
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner's
permit
so what's the craziest fight you've seen
was it in school out of school where was
it when was it our fights now in high
school if one person gets hit
six of his friends jump in
and then when they jump everyone else
jumps in it's like just a big rumble
there's no one-on-one fights we have a
building called the f building
and that bathroom is either used
for fighting if you're blinking or for
smoking okay those are the smoke and
what vape
yeah what a
what a different world so the f building
is fights don't smoke
i don't smoke at all i'm saying don't
smoke weed yeah if you're ever going to
do anything
i'll tell you what not to smoke
tobacco
and vapes
yeah and heroin
[Music]
so what's the craziest fight you've seen
we were coming back from lunch the kid
that was going to fight the other kid
had beat up a special ed kid oh my gosh
yeah that is terrible hey jeff
yeah
oh no hold on a minute hey go there
man you can't just roll by this oh
[Music]
come on now look at him
get it
wash his car watch his car watch where
you're going where is he he's right here
give me something i love at coron look
at it
look at you aloha
look at you give me that chrono
the virus y'all
[Music]
oh sorry in the middle of a special ed
story i found what's the special egg
kid's name i have a question i don't
know let's call joe joe
[Laughter]
hold on a second when we say special ed
we talking about like
the kid that just didn't bother to learn
how to read or we talking about like
yeah
okay all right okay you're about to run
a red light it's gonna be red
and there it is
this is where you hit the horn here
that's a horn
hit it
it's our first sword you just blew right
through a crosswalk you didn't see that
flashlight
he was all the way when you listen when
it's flashing you stop you just stop
because you don't know where they are
they could be coming on a bike
so
um what was i saying talking about
special ed kid they were going at it the
first punch was thrown he hit three back
to back to back he threw three punches
yeah they're just just rapid fire and
the
the kid that was getting punched was
backing up inside the classroom he came
up and grabbed a laptop computer like
the chromebook i have at home
he took grab a chromebook and smacked it
across his head cut a big gash in his
head he was just dripping blood
everywhere okay so the reason that
nobody jumped in to help the kid that's
getting his ass beat is because
previously he had fought a special egg
kid and everybody was like [ __ ] you dude
yes got it i don't know how to say it
it's very hard i don't know how to say
it without names i feel like the guy
with his ass out skating could have got
that out quicker
[Music]
[Music]
you